hi i'm coffee zilla and i alongside some
other researchers investigated safemen
and we just published a 40-minute
breakdown about why we think this
billion-dollar market cap company or
coin was fraudulent and the story
basically came down to the core promise
of safe moon basically the money was
supposed to be locked up untouchable and
it wasn't and i was finally ready to be
done with this story when suddenly
thomas smith who goes by the name papa
stepped forward to talk papa is the
former cto of safe mode and probably the
second most important person in their
history and he told me he was ready to
take some questions now to be honest i
respect the move it takes guts to take
on hard questions and what follows is
the highlights of our call together i
think we should start with the moment
that i confront papa about the team
basically committing fraud yeah and
frankly i mean to be honest i i'll just
be i'll just be honest because we've
been because i i feel like you know that
i'm just trying to get to the truth here
how is this not fraud uh which part
the part where you know it starts and
the everything's locked up guys
don't worry the money's locked up don't
worry we'll never touch it if we did
we'd go to jail and get a lawsuit
and then
subsequently everybody who owns the
contract
touches the lp and takes money how is
that not fraud i think
at first people like we were
trying to do the auto locking
and then when the organization started
john leverage to have it unlocked
so there were a lot of there was a lot
of shifting at first but ju no
the lp was taken from before john ever
got on board it was taken from march 5th
from the beginning money was being taken
out of the lp
i'm just i mean you definitely ask those
questions but i
don't have answers for you
here i i i'll send you the transaction
because i i don't i don't want to make a
i never like to make statements where
people know it's it's all right it's on
the blockchain it's on the blockchain
here i'll show
i'll send i'll send you the transaction
though just so you can check for
yourself i don't want you to think that
this is some kind of a
thing there he is taking 36 trillion
safe moon out of the lp on march 5th
how is this not fraught at this time
they're saying it's auto magically
locking up for four years you never have
to worry
and then you guys end up with millions
of dollars and the investors end up with
negative 90
i mean you can understand the problem
there
well yeah i see the problem for sure
okay so papa says he sees the problem
but what does that mean and how much did
papa get paid for this whole disaster
that's a huge question that i've had
from the beginning and so i asked him
about it
how much money did you profit from
safemen the amount that i got was right
around that
like the 2 million mark okay papa made
two million dollars according to him now
i personally think it might be more than
that but throughout our call that's the
number he really stuck to he said he
never had any secret wallets and any
other wallets were just paying lawyers
pr firms and other groups he only made
two million dollars according to him and
he said kyle paid him a lot of that
oh you got it from like kyle
yeah actually um he gave me a million
dollars in safe room at one point
but the question is where did kyle get
that money from because if you listen to
papa or anyone else in safe mode most of
safe moon's expenses come from kyle's
participation in the pre-sale and not
the liquidity pool
didn't you do you pay from the deployer
wallet
one trillion tokens to john uh the gabe
wallet
um so the deployer wallet uh we we
actually talked about this a lot in the
in the early days kind of like
buried beneath everything else today now
but
if you search for it i'm sure you'll
find it
the deployer wallet
the balance that was in it was one of
the early pre-sale um
like so he he threw in like 300
into the launch of it
i don't even think that he was the first
buyer stapindev ah yeah
yeah
so that was that was out of pocket for
him
whatever came out of that was out of
pocket this has always been safeman's
story the money papa made kyle made ben
phillips made the tokens caronie got it
all comes from the magical pre-sale
tokens but this cannot be true because
when you crunch the numbers most of
kyle's safeman tokens didn't come from
the pre-sale at all it didn't even come
from the tokens that kyle was constantly
buying or selling to illustrate this i
created a pie chart to show you the
proportion of kyle safeman holdings in
red is the amount he took from the
liquidity pool in blue is the pre-cell
and in yellow is the net safe mode he
purchased and then sold so as you can
see a huge amount of kyle's tokens came
from the liquidity pool meaning that
thomas has some explaining to do kyle
specifically because i know you got paid
and you paid caroni
a bunch of money
so when you actually look at kyle's lp
or his safe moon amounts he couldn't
have provided that had he not been
taking money from the lp
so
you guys your payment was coming from
liquidity that was supposed to be for
the investors
i mean i i really don't know anything
about what was happening with the owner
before i had it
you didn't know he was taking money out
no
hmm it seems like the former cto of a
blockchain project is saying he didn't
know what kyle had done on the
blockchain that he had basically been
pulling money out of the project from
the beginning now i'll be honest this
seems hard to believe later papa admits
it makes him uncomfortable the idea that
maybe some of his funds came from a
stolen liquidity pool that's what i was
told at the time anyway
you know you got it from the pre-sale
so i'm uncomfortable with that
if it didn't come from the pre-sale
right i mean that that's the whole
that's the whole problem i agree with
you i
so i so i actually agree with you
if
safe moondev had bought it in the
pre-sale
and he had decided to give you guys a
payout and that's how you guys made your
millions we wouldn't be talking right
the problem is that there was an express
thing that was the whole purpose of safe
moon the whole idea of safe moon was
we're going to go safely to the moon
it's in the name how are we going to go
safely to the moon will these other d5
projects rug we're not going to rug
what's not going to make us rug we're
auto magically locking the lp
except no we aren't we're taking from
the lp and that's actually how we're
making our millions of dollars it's
definitely obvious that that stance
changed
now here's where our conversation takes
a big turn we've already discussed the
whole i didn't realize this was from the
liquidity pool argument and here comes
their next argument basically safe moon
had pivoted and changed their story and
they had told people that they were
going to be taking money out of the
liquidity pool but is that true it's
definitely obvious that that stance
changed
i was locking the op myself i was right
but that but that stance changed april
24th first was your all-time high
you guys were still it's like the dave
store that i locked the 250 right right
but what i'm saying is you guys are
still changing the story at the time of
your all-time high so even if it changed
it's sort of like too little too late so
many people are on this ride you know
what i mean
see that's the whole problem with this
story even though safe moon eventually
told people that they would be taking
money out of the liquidity pool this
argument doesn't stand up because
they've been taking the money out before
they told anyone that's the critical
issue march 5th is the first time they
took money out and their official stance
was still changing in april papa didn't
seem to see this as too big of a problem
though we were pivoting
often
in those days
we started out on a wordpress page it
definitely couldn't handle this stuff
there was a lot of [ __ ] on there that
shouldn't have been there to begin with
but even even
your page
up in up in april
was
lp there's something about auto locking
lp or pink lp locked on pancake swap for
four years blah blah you're talking
about auto locking lp
people think you're auto locking it up i
mean
i was i was not making any
like i never made any claims as to
automatic or manual like i was showing
people i was telling people when i was
doing it
we did it all together in discord right
no i understand that maybe you were like
saying to people who asked but
but the organization as a whole had made
a certain representation right
so the organization said okay
i don't even think there was an
organization fully made yet
fine a webs a website somebody was
saying that this thing's auto locking
this is the whole thing behind safe moon
i mean it's in the name right
and y'all had it in your white paper
about the locking right the auto locking
you did so that's the
this is the whole problem that i'm
struggling with is i just keep coming
back to this feels like fraud this is
fraud i mean how how could it not be you
guys are millionaires your investors are
down 90 and you guys are million
millionaires directly from a
representation that was false
i mean we did tell people when we used
it
i didn't make any false we did change
things a lot now honestly this is where
things started to kind of go in circles
and so i'll just leave it to you to
decide how you want to feel about this
we changed it over time idea now i want
to move our conversation to talk about
john caroni did you ever suspect coronia
fraud
yes
holy sh
wait what you did win
i left right
like
when he started threatening to ruin the
lives of the people that
have been with me for 10 years
uh when
he got all that
the fake articles about jack the way
that he treated everybody
on the way out
i mean now safe mooners are gonna say oh
you got kicked out
that's what they try to say about
everyone they didn't say it about me but
i i know firsthand that they were trying
to prepare a um a statement
and then their um pr firm talk them down
wow
papa says he suspected coronia fraud
based on how he treated his fellow
employees and said he routinely
threatened his co-workers i continued to
dig about this and i also tried to
understand more about safe moon's true
origins specifically caronie's origins
so
is it true that caroni lived in a van or
like trailer
before uh safeman
yes
where did that come from
but it wasn't really it was um for him
it was it was a bougie trailer he did it
purposefully
well i'm just saying it's not like he
wasn't rich before safeman
no
okay i'm just wondering all right now i
want to show you something what i'm
about to show papa next are the multiple
million dollar payments to john caroni
from bitmart because the idea is after
establishing caroni was living in a
trailer around the time that he stumbled
into safe moon suddenly he's being paid
millions of dollars like how thomas
seemed equally perplexed jesus christ
what is that
that's uh that's just that's just a
couple
of
several million dollar payments to
caroni
that's
six million dollars right there
when was that was that was in june last
year
yep
yeah see i knew i knew a bunch of this
was happening
but
i didn't know it was going to him
so you knew somebody was profiting from
like well my understanding was that it
was very safe
right this was just weird how could papa
not have known caronie's wallet was
doing all of this because to begin with
he was one of the people who told me
that it was karoni's wallet before our
call he told me he knew it was caronie's
wallet immediately based on the last
four digits of the wallet 6 a b e he
said in a dm a yo that 6abe is john and
then later told me this how'd you also
know that oh no as soon as i someone
else pasted it to me and as soon as i
saw a 6abe
i knew exactly what wallet it wasn't
instantly yeah
so if you hear i think
forever ago there were a few hints to it
back at the amas and other you know like
discord discussions where he'd talk
about gabe
and people thought it was a person but
it's really just an address
oh this is so like kind of like you know
the lead speak
smart
um yeah i i'm not not very smart
actually uh now after telling me this
wallet was under john's control papa
would later tell me he remembered this
as a corporate account that's supposed
to be
a safe moon or a tano account he then
later clarified in dms quote that wallet
is a tano wallet not a safe moon wallet
confirmed now as a reminder tano is a
company john owned and controlled here's
the articles of incorporation he's the
number one member and most importantly
he's not putting the money back in the
lp
like he's supposed to to be honest
papa's surprise about all this stuff in
caroni's wallet is just hard to believe
and maybe he was just playing thumb i
don't know his explanation for a lot was
the fact that basically john ran the
show and he was basically just an
employee it's not like any of those
decisions were even wrongly run
so if
dude i get marching orders
you know you've got your basketball your
boss that's asking you every five
minutes if they're tracking what you're
saying or what if you're tracking what
they said you know what i mean like that
so you felt like you were just like an
employee
well yeah i was a tano employee the
whole time
even though you were the cto they were
this weren't you the cto
i was never a statement employer
and despite having uh a title or
whatever it's through the management
contractor
which
was a drag again that's another mess
that i need to deal with
and this idea was a recurring theme papa
told me that basically everything he did
with the safe moon contract wasn't his
idea it was john's this includes their
bitmark deal and how they used the
liquidity pool papa told me that part of
the way they were making money with
bitmart was a money market account he
told me they sold safe moon to bitmart
in exchange for money i asked them where
they got that safe
what does that mean they bought it otc
over the counter from safeword but yeah
how did how did safe moon have that safe
moon to sell where did they get that
from right so the the migration the
whitson pancakes there were a ton of
migrations
um the v1 to v2 pancake swap so it's
it's v1 safe moon
with v1 pcs and the migration of v2 pcs
so when that happened we had to move the
liquidity over and we had to find
kind of
weird ways we had to pull liquidity in
order to move it over to v2 and in doing
so that
there was a lot of satan that came out
so there was an accident that wasn't put
in v2
yeah
why wasn't it putting v2 it just
it was it was it was given to
or well not given but john john sold it
to the uh well i guess you could i don't
even know how to classify what you would
say this transaction is but so because
the exchanges need to obtain the
statement they got it from
that
that pool
and the safe moon was intended
to be sent to the holders anyway so we
figured
you know the liquidity is still the
liquidity
now i'll be honest the liquidity is
still the liquidity is a pretty weird
answer basically they're saying those
millions of dollars we made oh it's all
just part of the liquidity it's all
legit and i had to ask thomas about this
where he thought this money that was
being generated came from so i'm like
not satisfied by this like like the
exchange deal makes no sense to me i
don't understand why like why millions
of dollars or 55 million needs to go to
bitmark for exchange deals this makes no
sense to me and what john was saying
apparently as he told someone with the
bitmart deal they were about to be put
into a new tax bracket
right
he said what he said we're about to be
put into a new tax bracket
why would he say that if he wasn't going
to personally profit from it
right
so it sounds like something
here's my so here's my question like
okay
explain this to me because obviously we
both know money can't come from nowhere
so
let's say
if you're just migrating the funds from
v2 v1 to v2
no money is generated for safemen
if you migrate v1 to v2 but you do it in
that weird way where you put a buy order
and you end up with millions of dollars
of safe moon and then you sell that safe
moon to an exchange
all of a sudden money has been created
for safemen
and you're telling me that has no price
impact for the bot for the for the
people of safemen
how's that possible
the price i guess the the value impact
will come from volatility but
only on the v1
v2
pcs
the money has come from somewhere it
didn't come from nowhere right
right
how can that be how can how could safe
moon be generating free money
right and
the same argument could be made about an
unlocked lp in john's hands
so the reason why he wants it unlocked
is so that he can use it
right so he doesn't have to go through
this process
likely
so that's a lot easier than just
you know
so at these other exchanges we're so
willing to do this deal because
save them comes with a lot or wealth
they've come with a lot of volume
yeah they're going to get a ton in fees
right so i'm still i'm so so again like
use for something other than what he
should have been using it for the man
should be called out
so like so here's what i'm seeing like
safe moon is making millions
the exchanges are making millions
yeah
losing millions
right the people who
take the fees
the investors
that's where all the money came from
yeah there it is folks money doesn't
come from nowhere if you can take
anything from this video
if safe moon suddenly is making millions
it has to come from somewhere and if
it's from the lp that's a problem
because again that was supposed to be
locked up now i also talked to papa
about the fees bitmart stated they were
taking to give back to the development
team to be placed in the lp and i wanted
to know were they doing that so the
second part of this is
that i got this from their website so
they say that
and i understand maybe they weren't
perfect about this but they say
they charge trading fees and that
five percent will be directly
redistributed okay we know that that's
reflections and then it says five
percent will be returned to the
developers to be added back to the
liquidity pool for safe moon tokyo oh
yeah that's something that happened
after i was that's the v2 thing that i
left
before v1 was discontinued
um no that is this is this is from april
2nd 2024 so this is this should be um
this should be last year
okay so
that's i mean that's not really how we
did it though up until v2 when swapping
liquify was turned on
so we we
only ever manually transferred lp for
when that like that if the lp
contracts need to be upgraded but still
there's like there's a ton of liquidity
on v1 still
right and it's going to be there for
like four years there's we've discovered
a few ways that can be withdrawn still
um there obviously people have found
bugs in the v1 and v2 contracts v2
contract can be updated it's it's a
proxy so you can change whatever is
behind the proxy
the trick is maintaining the balance
or balances so
you said you guys really didn't do it
that way
you mean do you mean by that you weren't
paid by bitmart or you didn't put the
whatever you were paid by bitmark back
into the lp oh no i mean like bit
bitmark didn't pay safe moon to list
with bitmark
no no i understand that but they say
they're gonna give you guys tokens so
they're saying basically look every
every time you trade on bitmart we're
taking ten percent of it
five percent were giving back to the
bitmart holders and five percent were
giving back to safe moon to put into the
lp
um yeah so all of the
on each of the uh centralized exchanges
the way that it's supposed to work if
tokenomics are you know quote-unquote
enabled
each
it simulates the v1
process where 10 feet
uh
and then
uh half of it goes to the market making
and then half the other half goes to the
um
the holders
um and obviously there were problems
with that along the way because it
wasn't automated
but because of that process
rather than them just collecting it and
doing it themselves they opted all of
them opted to purchase it from saving
because it was easier for them they
didn't have to upgrade their systems and
deal with devs and all this other stuff
but where did that other five percent go
is what i'm saying so you're saying like
i've honestly i have no idea what
happened inside the market making
accounts
well that's not a very good answer okay
so papa says he doesn't know what
happened inside the market-making
accounts but he says he doesn't think
they were putting it into the lp again a
massive problem as i said i believe this
is a fraud no matter how you slice it
because of the simple premise that they
said the funds were locked up they
weren't and they used a bunch of it now
they did pivot the stance later but
again we've addressed this they had been
taking money well before that and the
company had reached values of like
billions of dollars by the time they had
disclosed it as for the specifics of
what happened with things like bitmart
payments to kyle a lot of those
questions remain unanswered i think the
only person who can truly tell us is
john caroni and like i've said i've
reached out for over a month and he has
yet to respond meanwhile the person who
is talking i'm grateful to him but i
find his answers less than satisfying
what do you think should be done about
this
well i think the first thing that
happens is we go to court
but here's but here's what i'm saying
here's what i'm saying do you think it's
right
for you to have two million dollars for
kyle to have however much he has
for john to have millions of dollars all
you guys to walk away millionaires and
all your investors a lot of them are
down 90 do you think that's fair
well i know i know you're
frustrated and you've got a lot of
really good points
from my perspective which i should
probably be
only answering on for that part is i
perform a service for money i'm a dev
i've always been a dev this is what i do
i've been doing it for a long time
um so if i work out a deal with the org
that's controlling me
to get paid for something i'm providing
real value on my end
well i guess that's their last defense i
deserve the money because i worked for
it i personally don't find that too
credible but i want to know what you
think in the comments below and that's
basically it pump the stock thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one